thank you alejandro yes i'm here with
uh what must be a very happy on each
geary it took you a while
round three you got that loss but now
you're back how does that feel
yeah i'm very happy you know the i'm a
very experienced player and the more
experienced i get the more i realize
chess is just about luck there's really
no
really nothing else well i would say
there was some resilience yesterday
against
wesley you fought for like six hours to
defend that position
no i mean i already told you my
conclusion uh you cannot change it to
the one sentence i've been playing chess
for many years uh i've been studying a
lot and i've came to conclusion that
chess is all about luck so just like
whatever you say now is not going to
change that
okay let's go through this game and uh
where were you lucky in this game
it's various various points
well to begin with i've mixed something
up i think
yeah make something up but it doesn't
matter
then i
thought i realized that i mixed
something up
too late like around here i realized
that i make something we also have
your uh second on the beans are
he also said that you worked him until 4
a.m in the morning so that doesn't sound
like luck to me
no no but he worked but um i mixed
things up just
um and i realized
here that i have nothing and then i
realized well
it appears that i've mixed something up
and then to be honest i was
um sort of i thought this is i mean it's
a draw
in various ways though bishop takes c3
is not it because i will take on e6 and
this is nasty i think
this is very nasty but there are
multiple ways i like bishop d5
i thought um move like e6 i would put
knight on d4 but i mean
okay it's not serious also here i
thought he takes this one
and then i push the c point but i
thought
i'm not in time because he's got bishop
f6 bishop h4 hitting that
f2 pawn so i was frankly
uh thinking that i mean if i were to get
uh pawn to c6 like maxim said he was
worried about i am better but i really
don't think i can let's say bishop of
six
computer though is um see maybe there is
maybe there's something to it
yes yeah maxim calculated that actually
um i just assumed to be honest it was so
drawn this position like
the margin is so large uh the engine
doesn't even represent the margin like
it's almost like whatever sort of pawn
you you win the margin for a draw is so
big that
i didn't take it too seriously and um i
thought my opening has sort of failed
and okay draw is also not the end of the
world when you are
not in great shape so i thought okay
maybe the draw is okay and then
but i was still surprised that we got
this because now i am pressing but then
as the more i started thinking about it
the more i realized it's also fine
yeah it's just very fine the thing is
that i've got these pawns that are
a little crippled and just very hard to
make progress really
though it was still important at one
point that i played rook d5 because if i
don't it's a draw on the spot i thought
because he can take take and then
he's got this g5 idea okay i can still
play like that but i thought this would
be
annoying then i would have to put my uh
my king i don't know like
she would start start going back and
forth
yeah maybe maybe i can go though at some
point through h1 or even kg for you
but okay i just didn't like this i
thought it was okay to block this and
after h6 g5
uh he's not really after my pawn but of
course like it's a draw in general
um but at least
i'm not sure i want i think i would be
even happier to get rid of the weakness
on h3 but
basically i want that he doesn't have
targets on the king's side
and then he can force a draw and that's
usually the first step when you try the
session end game you should make sure he
cannot force a draw
and then once he cannot then i will see
what i can do
maybe of course in theory what i have to
do is one day bring the king over to the
queen side but it's a long way to go
and um so here my plan is to bring the
bishop to b5
from where it protects the a4 pawn and
also sometimes goes to e8
i was thinking um maybe he should okay
like here i thought he has the best
position ever and i thought he should
put
pawn on the f5 king to f6 this is more
more to the point i thought um i was
expected because it's more active more
in his style
of course it's a mini target but i think
it's much more comfortable because here
something is clumsy about this like the
some scenarios where i put bishop on h5
look to
fade maybe but the thing is that
still here yeah nothing is really going
on but i don't want my bishop on b5
right
maybe someone i want to trade the h pawn
with h4 and then bishop from b5 will
try to hit f7 via bishop e8 as in the
game
and yeah sort of i mean i mean it's a
very very long way to go and i by no
means thought i'll ever win this but i
thought okay we have
at least i have um much more than you
know what i thought
like here like here i thought it's gonna
be just to draw very fast and then here
i was already kind of pressing
and he he did a very risky thing i mean
his margin for a draw is enormous here
and he uh went for the bishop and game
which
could be a draw are you surprised by
that how by his decision
um after a while i was shocked by that
because at first i thought that okay
maybe
at first i thought i missed this move
because i didn't consider it but then i
don't like wait but i thought i'm just
sort of pushing my phone to a7
and then i realized what he wants i mean
see
for him it makes some sense because he
either suffers for like two more hours
and then who knows or maybe if it's a
draw it's just a draw
so it makes some sense what he did for
sure but he
i think what he must might have missed
at first he might have missed i don't
include that
because that's very important in this uh
variation
uh king 2 i think e7 king g4 f6
f6 yeah and now i don't have a 4 while
if i start with this and he does the
same thing
now i do have a four and he doesn't have
bishop takes e3
and this position is i think it's
winning i think it's
wait it's not we thought that ah yes no
but i thought
i don't know why bishop did too but i
thought you know how it's winning i'm
going to go here king h7
is not winning but then how do you make
any progress
let's see let's see let's see let's see
let's see hashtag
yeah but i have some chapters yeah but i
was thinking about it i have some
check i want to take only six at some
point right um one idea but
also i have some kind of bishop h5 wait
so if i take on e6 you switch the king
to c6 bishop to d4 that's your defense
uh i thought i have a check let me let's
say here
you go here
wait testing this thing let's see bishop
here or something
at some point king eight i thought
actually i was i was thinking if it's
winning or not but
suppose i decided it's probably winning
let's see yeah we have e5 let me
let me think if i okay basically um i do
have a concept
right or not with which i mean no i
don't well now i can just go here
so let me try to bring the bishop ah and
the moment i bring the bishop
so if i have bishop d3 king j8 am i
winning then let's see
okay it's getting a bit awkward but you
know i have to bear with me now
um it's also drawn i think h5
in bishop period of king g6 so if and if
i had
yeah this is also a draco's king g5 okay
so there's
you just draw i'm getting some uh
feedback that we're getting some results
right now yeah
yeah no we could do it two more hours
two more hours tomorrow you know
privately
thank you very much janice for joining
us and once again congratulations thanks
for watching
i told you for this lucky way thank you
guys thank you